what now
go back up crack some heads open drag
the bodies inside
welcome back so ready
rogue should be here any minute
let's get out of here you're just gonna
talk to rogue about smasher right
then you'll hand me the wheel and hop
back in the passenger seat
that is the plan don't worry
i'll be gentle you might even enjoy it
actually regretting this already
i'm ready
oh [ __ ] time
look a little different fuss with your
hair or
[Music]
[ __ ] it's good to be back never knew
you'd gone off somewhere
what's your poison
blue glass
uh
well give me another you got it
[Music]
green way to get started
cassie's writer may mean anything to you
tattoo guy how do you know we go back
we'll find him got a salon in watson
hershey street
so what'll it be billy goat or the other
one
other one he's gonna love it
sure he will
jeremiah grayson i heard he's an
operator for smasher
but you didn't hear that from me hey who
are you again
yeah could say we had something in
common
ruby collins sloppy second for grayson
after i banged
[Music]
hey drink slinger
[Music]
though
[Music]
left or right
i think i got something better hey
you ruby
what you've heard about me let's get out
of here
tell you what i heard then you'll show
me if i'm right
just got a little biz to take care of
first
yo get your [ __ ] paws off ruby
this ain't going anywhere with you
she's on that clock got it
[Music]
[ __ ] i missed it
[Applause]
be waiting outside
you waiting for me i go back to my place
[Music]
where to martin street but take the long
way
look good on you got a light
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Laughter]
[Music]
dr grayson
hello night city
v
spit blood first thing everyone
talk about something else please sure
first time you walked up since there was
something familiar about you
blah blah johnny told you
did we you know
no gunk was too drunk
he called me early morning of course i
thought it was you
and i thought cute kid too bad he's gone
completely
whacked you came to see for yourself huh
morbid curiosity mm-hmm
and i found johnny silverhand
smasher he tell you about him
yes didn't know he'd come back to nc
johnny found some way to get at him wait
grayson jeremiah grayson
works for smasher johnny got a tip off
some stripper don't ask me how
ebony just that still
let me see what i can do we're gonna get
that son of a [ __ ]
know what smash has been up to all this
time disappeared after the soccer tower
assault in 2023.
all thought he was gone for good then
suddenly reappeared
did a few mondo jobs for arasaka then
went right back to ground
nobody's seen him in years except
grayson
apparently can i help at all
in your state you're useless
almost i'll buzz you when i learn
something
okay
unbelievable that bastard's somewhere in
your head
oh
oh [ __ ]
you ought to be the one puking right now
yeah well life ain't fair yeah you sure
picked the right moment to bolt out of
my body
ought to be happy i left it all
for a moment there it did seem like you
were thinking about
staying i mean you had such a good time
don't trust me after all huh i know you
thought about it
saw it i did exactly what we agreed
let's get out of here
the hell is this place place where you
can puke all over the carpet no problem
beggar not chooser
uh
v got to the bottom of ebonica
flicked pings to some contacts grayson
buzzed familiar for a friend from the
olden days
he did some digging found something
section of the dogs that's maelstrom
turf
so why are these docks called abunika
pretty sure it's got nothing to do with
some long dead mayor
did wrong actually it's not the dogs
it's an old container ship
named after the guy
meaning you found grayson he really got
an in with smasher
come see me afterlife we'll talk
okay
so feeling better
no
[Music]
so
foreign
down
[Music]
had something for her too ah
minor details that v
crispin weyland he's helping us
evie i hear your haunting smasher
ready we'll talk on the way
like everybody in this town that is nice
but me don't share my father's
aspirations
so we expect to live longer than he did
we going let's go
good luck
[Applause]
[Applause]
help you exactly he made sure we'll find
grayson at home when we stopped by
so we know where to look for him
you a little something try it off
this johnny's jacket a replica
made to order real jacket must have
disintegrated into dust years ago
thanks
next
so
jump in
what johnny say about me no you two talk
all the time
oh johnny talks about himself mostly
hmm right
you sure you're up for this what
you getting cold feet no just
i don't want to see johnny haze you adam
smashes his
obsession not yours thinks so
just trying to play fair
so weird he didn't run into smasher
before now
came up in conversation time to time
yeah but
you never tried to track him down listen
v
fact that johnny's back changes things
okay
okay sure believe me
i know
okay here's as far as we go
might be our lucky day drop grayson and
smasher in one go
fucker's got to be around here somewhere
so what's our plan waylon saw grayson
somewhere around the dogs
he was with somebody smasher
so i hope gotta get to the maelstrom
data term first
should be some info on smasher there
main stash house
data terms there
okay we can start too many rats around
better wait till a little darkness
creeps in
and in the meantime we do what wait
and watch
okay good as it's gonna get
maelstrom's got the dogs covered and
you'll cover me come on
let's go she's tense cover her just in
case
i got an idea wait a second
then follow me
yeah hmm
[Music]
go
what's a weekly
[Music]
all right you got it scan it see if
there's anything we can use
i'll watch the door no knows exactly
where to find him
she's stalin told ya rogue's still
scared of the [ __ ]
looks like they're hiding out on the
ship okay
let's see what we turn up
there she is the ebony
[Music]
not looking so hot even shittier they'll
have eyes on
let's go
kind of hard gotta search the deck okay
why are you even doing this i'm settling
a score
vengeance
oh [ __ ] you hear that grayson yeah
no not that [ __ ] shooting at me with
my own gun
delorean 35-16 signature
not yours i don't think grayson
oh my rogue you and me not playing for
the same team anymore
guess i'm not at all surprised seems
your specialty
slipping shivs in the backs of allies
where's smasher
could crack your skull like an eggshell
know that
you'd still be able to talk for a little
while
but i'm happy to talk ever wonder how
rogue survived after the attack on the
tower
how in hell no one ever hunted her down
her alone
out of all that atlantis trash cause i
do
i truly wonder how far she had to go
to set herself up so comfy
could she whose crack did she have to
lick to
where's smasher now
with the arsakas but i think you know
that already
when's he do back never
faithful old adam's just been named
ahead of security there
oh not coming back to this rat hole ever
i stayed behind just to tie off his
loose ends
[ __ ] could say that again you two will
never jump that high
smasher's out of your reach but don't
feel bad
he'll find you himself likes to resolve
[ __ ] like this in person
gonna lead us to smash your ass face
even if i wanted to he don't trust me
enough to
hey why are you so interested in smasher
anyway
i'm not interested in silverhand and
what happened to him
johnny silverhand
what do you want to know
smasher ever tell you what he did with
silverhand's body
that into him huh plan to exhume that
scop
or you just want to hear how he died
soaked in his own
piss neuron scorched by soul killer
what did they do with him
near the oil fields buried out there
101 northbound then head for the
landfill
dig deep enough mighty find a
[ __ ] smear heard enough finish it let's
send this quickly
want to rip my eyes out just looking at
him no no wait
i got something silver hand you're in
damn right
i could give you something
you deserve extinction do i end him
yes meaning do what you think is right
smashers got something that was johnny's
it could be yours just gotta let me live
don't want a damn thing from you
good one dicksburg less
let's delta
pointless this whole thing still no
leads
nowhere to go from here [ __ ] v tell her
johnny says you'll get him yet oh yeah
we'll tell him
[ __ ] can't even have a normal convo with
him
smasher [ __ ] you don't get it
this isn't about smasher he's just the
goddamn tip of the iceberg
even if we get him what does that get us
leave her alone v she'll get it together
at times like this she prefers to be
alone
okay i get that let's hit those oil
fields
i want to see what it looks like out
there
[Music]
oh [ __ ] think i know what it is
let's see what we got here
take that rag off it okay
my ride hop in
i'll even let you drive
[Applause]
up
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
can't believe they bothered to truck it
all the way out here
it's better than the junkyard where i
landed
so that's how it is
nothing here at all
what did you expect headstones flag and
flowers
yeah right i don't know
a marker something anything
we'll figure something out
[Music]
better now
a bit but let's say it was my real grave
what would you write here lies johnny
silverhand
wanna talk
night city legend
sounds good but what does it really mean
what did i achieve shouting chipping
into a bunch of angry
pimply kids
[Music]
gave those kids hope the suits couldn't
buy
everything i remember what i thought on
stage
that even if they all died for their
ideals
it'd be worth it but when i look at you
listen i realize i [ __ ] up a lot of
things
either let down or used every last
person who gave me their trust
blind selfish bastard that i was
but i've managed one thing for now not
to [ __ ] this up
what we have
it's been a long bumpy road but we made
it
most people i thought were my friends
they couldn't even stand to be in the
same room with me
you're [ __ ] closest to me by a long
shot
there 24 7.
and yet you don't seem to hate my living
guts
you were a real dick wipe at first
you sort of deserved it
remember waking up at victor's not
knowing about me
i'm seeing things i'm scared
then moaning at misties about how you
didn't want to die
remember you whining for smokes in the
middle of night complaining about not
being able to kill me
never thought we'd make it this far
still feel like you can't breathe in
here yeah
not saying it's great but it's different
sometimes when i wake up feels like i'm
back for a while
what do you mean back well
like i got this body to myself like i'm
free
seconds later feels like i'm missing
something
something really important then i
realize you're there
always were and this stupid wave of
relief
washes over me
i have similar dreams sometimes that
you never died that i'm you
not like i think what would johnny do
it's more i do something and i feel
[ __ ] great like i've uh
finally started to fit into this world
hmm
probably not a great sign we better do
something
fast when you said you let your friends
down
did you mean rogue rogue
alt kerry santiago
not always lost yet at least with rogue
can't pretend nothing's changed over 50
years
can't just insert myself into our life
biz really got to her you can't leave it
like this
i don't think might be right she was
acting
weird you want to talk to her you know
did promise her i'd take her to the
movies
long long ago good idea
call her for me ask if she's free some
night
thing is you'd have to surrender control
again
yeah i'll call her
okay that's delta nothing to see here
after all worth coming out all the same
absolutely thanks of all the heads i
could have popped up
in hella glad it was yours
you